it was late in the evening when Hong
Kong's International Airport descended
into chaos
protesters had detained and roughed up a
man they suspected of being an
undercover agent from mainland China
paramedics tried to intervene but in
vain so police were sent to help him
given the current animosity between
protesters and police violence seemed
inevitable scuffles broke out
even though officers had clearly said
their mission wasn't to disperse the
sit-in now in its fifth day anger at
what protesters say is police brutality
in dealing with them has fired up these
airport demonstrations after bringing
the airport to a standstill on Monday
there were again calls on social media
on Tuesday to converge on the departure
hall and protester numbers began to
build during the day they blocked access
to the security and immigration areas
and used cars to close down the check-in
desks just a short while ago we watched
as the check-in counters were closed and
then it was officially announced that
departures have been cancelled again for
the second day running one of the
world's busiest aviation hubs
still into the evening passengers kept
arriving to learn the bad news and tried
to figure out what to do hundreds of
flights have now been cancelled with a
growing backlog Hong Kong's government
is continuing to stand behind the
tougher police tactics after they said
they were facing increasing violence
earlier in the day Hong Kong's embattled
leader Carrie Lam gave a press briefing
to warn of the economic damage of
closing the airport but gave no hint of
backing away from her and Beijing s
resolute stance the chief executives
responsibility is to ensure that Hong
Kong remains a safe and orderly and
law-abiding City that is my utmost
responsibility flights have now resumed
once more the protesters are threatening
to disrupt services again with the
knowledge that if they can get enough
numbers they can achieve it